greetings from podcast Ville it's
Tuesday the 16th of October the Church
of what's happening now is brought to
you by blue a blue apron delivers
farm-fresh ingredients and step-by-step
recipes to your door blue aprons mission
is to make incredible home cooking
accessible to everyone so check out this
week's menu and get your first three
meals for free at blue apron Tom slash
Joey again that's blue apron com slash
Joey get your first three meals free
blue apron a better way to cook let me
talk to you about something right 66% of
men lose their hair by the age of 35 but
I'll tell you that it's a shame you know
the thing is when you start to notice
the hair loss it's too late and we got a
solution for hems calm is a
one-stop-shop for hair loss fit skin
care and sexual wellness for men okay
number one thanks to science baldness
can be optional hims connects you with
real doctors and medical grade solutions
to treat hair loss they they use
well-known generic equivalents to name
brand prescriptions to help you keep
your hair no snake oil pills a
gas-station counter replacement this is
prescription solutions backed by science
so order now what I'm gonna do is the
church the family you get a trial month
of hymns for five dollars right now
while supplies last five hours that's
all I'm asking you for five hours to get
you beautiful you look like Elvis in
heat you understand me see the website
for full details this would cost
hundreds if you went to a doctor or a
pharmacy go to hims comm slash Joey
that's for hims comm slash Joey again
for hims dot-com slash Joey the church
is also brought to you by family my
bookie all right listen watching
football is fun and the UFC and you know
the NBA is right around the corner
Duggars are [ __ ] all right you want to
sit there with a bunch of guys even
[ __ ] nachos that's your business me
I'm gonna sit with four [ __ ] guys I'm
trying to get a little bit of money
whether it's a small twenty or some or
two thousand that's what my book is
there for all right if you're the kind
of
wasting better little or what a lot like
playing the numbers and the roulette
we could pick three teams to win and if
you hit all three you could turn 100
into 600 log in to my bookie right now
and double your money that's right he's
gonna choke when he come log in to my
bookie right now and double your money
use promo code Church CH you are CH and
you'll get your first deposit matched
100% that means you put a G no then you
got another G no god forbid you're
blasting on a Thursday night game who's
better than uncle Joey nobody that's
promo code Church you play you win you
get paid kick that [ __ ] melee
notice me [ __ ] that's what
everybody's thinking nowadays we're in
studio with my man Gomez I don't I like
the little Luis Gomez but I like the
name Gomez better get back to my Addams
Family you know if he's speaking about
him he likes and he always corrects me
on it it's J Gomez a little bit one
koresh I'm just gonna throw it out there
and [ __ ] former world champion and
just great all-around guy mr. Michael
Bisping congratulations Thank You Joey
pleasure [ __ ] great to have you both
in the studio this is exciting it's been
a long time coming we talked about doing
this show a few times now um and we're
able to make this one happen which is
great because you're the best you guys
do your show once a week well it used to
be once a week believe you me but lately
it's been twice we keep call it a bonus
episode
I'm retired these days I don't have much
to do I'm like [ __ ] ulis to another show
yeah oh yes bonus episode you know who's
you know life's going nowhere when I've
got doing five bonus episodes a week
yeah it's like really shoes you want to
hang you want to talk to a friend which
have to call it a bonus episode those
just alone in Orange County
exactly no how do you know my 39 you're
beautiful oh great God well thank you I
appreciate that thank you very much
happy to be retired
very much so very much yeah I mean I
spoke about it on our show you know I
definitely went out on my own terms but
I you know a lot of injuries over the
years I still feel like I could
definitely compete in fact I know I can
but you got things going on busy you
know so ya can't do it forever my wife
wanted me to be tired for years you know
she wanted me me too
hire a long time ago but yeah yeah very
happy with it you look great and a
question you know it's it changes it
changes and what we do and what they do
is an art and it's kind of similar you
have to know where you stand and we're
not stand and training and it's the same
thing you know hmm I feel like when I
shot that Netflix special it was like
how Holloway felt after you got beat up
by Connor
you know what Holloway and Dustin
Poirier both improved dramatically after
they lost to Connor because you see what
your faults are a lot more like I saw I
[ __ ] up onstage in a way I mean I had
a good setting on I'm excited but it's
coming out but it's weird how we grow as
artists and fighters how you well it's
it's an old cliche but you learn more
from your losses than you do from your
victories I mean it's absolutely true I
mean of course it's great to win fights
you want to go out there and kick ass
and win and be the man all that [ __ ] you
don't learn anything in fact if anything
you just pick up bad habits you get away
with the stuff that you shouldn't be
getting away with because one day
someone's gonna get you one day
someone's gonna make you honest when you
lose a fight case in point when I lost
Dan Henderson
but first lost in the UFC [ __ ]
terrible loss you know I changed a lot
of [ __ ] change a lot of things and it
made me a better man made me a better
fire same thing as y'all saying we stand
up with anything really you know you
know I think in the beginning was Santa
that's why I think you you're just not
very good in the beginning so you're
just you're dealing with those losses a
lot so that's why you learn so much in
the beginning because you just kind of
stink and you like have to you have to
get up and want to sort of to do it in
the beginning it's [ __ ] weird I
wouldn't I don't think I could ever
start over again
thinking about it could you could you go
back and start over a very beginning see
I was thinking then I used to be a
nightclub DJ for a year for 50 years DJ
Mikey B prior to being a and I fired it
yeah but it's very different scene you
got a you know good DJ and you got to
play all the shitty [ __ ] venues in
the empty nightclubs or oh my god the
seven people in here is going on
Manchester
yeah yeah Manchester great at Manchester
I'm from a small town just outside of
Manchester all really solid DJs 16 and
what type of music what dance music
house music - yeah yeah yeah
it's really big in England right it's
something huge massive dancing yeah yeah
see I started martial arts eight years
old and I was obsessed with it that's
all I did but then I left school at 16 I
got a job working some shitty factory
and walking home and I popped into my
friend's house to smoke a joint and he
had some turntables I was a holy [ __ ] I
thought it was the coolest thing I ever
saw
so [ __ ] martial arts let's do let's try
and become a DJ and I put all my efforts
into that really and then when I
realized that I'm never gonna be a
[ __ ] world famous DJ getting paired
tons of money I went back to martial
arts and came to the UFC that's pretty
much my life story in a minute I hear
like guys who start fighting in there
like five for fifty bucks in the valley
at a bar in the beginning it's the same
one night as we do yeah and then you get
like nine and oh and the amateur [ __ ]
it's a racket and then you sign on to
some lower league and then you'd knock
three [ __ ] out there and then
the UFC comes a-calling and the first
fight could be short notice or whatever
yeah it's it's like what you know I'll
never forget I was I was writing
something today about mm how I thought I
had the pieces together in my life and I
got a call to do the desert and with
David towel and some of the New York
comic
well I never took called called the book
of back in the night before the night of
the show when I got to the green room
they switched the lineup I was Tim out
oh man
and Here I am so you might not oh I was
on it also it was working with Kemal
right oh [ __ ] and he was on the show
still he was still on whatever yeah I
throw a big [ __ ] deal and I walked in
there prepared for a towel like that 27
minutes set before it's out yeah and now
Tim Allen's day and I didn't know what
the [ __ ] to do and he was pretty cool
when he told me it's you know you learn
as you go along like it since the same
thing as fighting you just learned as
you go along and then when you get beat
by something new you switch it up like
some nights you're like I'm gonna go out
then improvise and you get lit up I get
a bag of dog [ __ ] and now you either go
well I'm gonna improvise you get better
at it I'm not gonna have it do it again
it's the same thing with fighting you
know yeah well I mean I think it's just
you know whatever it is it takes a
weird it's a weird personality type to
get into either one when you really
think about it they're like you know
getting on stage people are really
[ __ ] terrified about people that
haven't done it before speaking in front
of even do the first time I first couple
years I did Santa I think they're number
two on the list yeah death and then yeah
public speaking I look speaking but I'm
sure far behind that is probably getting
into a fistfight or being punched in the
face people just for you to want to do
it before you know how to do it it takes
a weird thing like why would you what
are you drawing we kind of or fight out
of fun Wyatt before you know how to
fight drawing you to put yourself in
that type of danger it's it's just a
most people think it's [ __ ] crazy
I agree with what you say it and
probably more so these days because
these days as a sports bigger ufc's
bigger and it's more open it's a job
opportunity for more people these days
but from my background and Who I am it
wasn't a [ __ ] job opportunity this is
what I did it's all I know I had no
education I was just out there scrapping
guys and I wanted to make something of
my life and give my children a better
life you know so it wasn't like a
conscious decision of I'm gonna be a
fire it was a fire a lot of old-school
guys that's the same kind of thing I'm
not unique I'm not special you know back
in the day when there wasn't much money
to be made but now you look you know
you've got these people fresh-faced
education great family so what the [ __ ]
you fighting in an octagon for you got
tons of options you know so I think
these days is a new breed of fires you
know well I mean everyone loves money
but I can't admit the first time I got
punched in the face I think I'd be
retired good what does it like the first
time you get punched in the face by like
an actual fight or not like just someone
out by a kid I know you should get
punched in the face a lot my mum with
the heel the sharp end over the heel of
her shoe was the particularly painful
one I did karate from the age of six to
16 and I used to go to these 3-point
tournaments where there were no contact
from the head it was only from the top
of the neck to the body in the waist and
I would go through these tournaments and
I'd win Michael business I was pretty
[ __ ] good karate and forget about the
form time
I would [ __ ] you up with forums because
I would practice someone who's with a
string and the thing and I would beat
Bob my head and throw the punches under
the strings I was great and then
something happened in the 6th grade I
got to a [ __ ] real fistfight and it
was horrified cats a bull [ __ ] when I
just gotta bite your nose off I tried to
kick the guy and the guy went right
through it and he broke my nose I got
one good shot on him again the black eye
and we were both in the same grade I
could taste the blood coming from my
nose in my mouth the whole [ __ ] you
know type of deal and I had an idea
right there I'm like I don't think this
fighting [ __ ] on me
and then once my eye went through my
[ __ ] and I was a tough guy I thought I
was a tough guy and I started flipping
these [ __ ] perverts down the Hudson
County Park and one and I would go down
there with six friends and we flip a guy
and take this money that type of [ __ ]
married guys who want to get that dick
suck but one that I was down in myself
today
[Laughter]
no one knows Michael Bisping my name is
doing the bag I was [ __ ] doing five
sets of six I had this guy by 20 pounds
I thought I hit him with everything I
got he just flipped his face huh look
back at me
Michael Bisping threw 20 punches at me
in the dark and he was black right now
white dude just let me out Michael
Bisley and I had my hands up like this
like a boxer I don't know how he was
getting through he punched me 20 times I
punched him the neck out of fear my god
this is all I had and he held on to his
neck and I ran around him and I did a
four for 40 in 3.2 minutes and I never
went back to Hudson County parties but I
knew when I looked at me I had lumps all
over my head from the beat he gave me
and I knew right then to them like that
tough-guy [ __ ] ass and in my life right
there yeah I do not want to be a tough
guy I do not want to collect for the
Mafia
don't want to do little hmm well it's a
it's a weird thing because there's
people who are like there's people who
are down to like you know like if I go
to a bard so he tries to [ __ ] with me I
will not let that happen I carry myself
in a way that I you know I'm just not
but I'm not [ __ ] tough like that like
I you see people you see like videos on
the internet work people get into fights
and then they hit the guy and the guy
goes down and then they keep going and
they want to hurt this person and
there's none of that in me like it's
like you know I'm I grew up where like
you get into a fight out back with us
some dude you punch each other a couple
times you have a beer afterwards and
that's sort of the end of it then you
see like real-deal [ __ ] like you're
living in an 80s movie by the sounds of
it yes you get into a fight come on
buddy you got me good there John
let's go share a Bud Light did you go he
breaks a pool heel on my arm I'm like
hit man we could be friends now but it's
just like hood [ __ ] people that are
like real-deal you know that know that
are violent and I think that's really
the difference forget just like you know
knowing how to fight or anything else
like they're like real violent people
out there when you said you're getting
to like a lot of fights when your kid
with you was like some violent [ __ ] like
crazy [ __ ] like that a lot of crazy [ __ ]
I don't really want to talk about you
know burn I will to a certain degree but
yeah yeah yeah I mean I grew up in a
small town called clithero which is a
beautiful place but and there was so
much [ __ ] violence that it really was
just nothing too crazy but I just mean
fistfights but lots of them that were
hardcore you know um people would you
know people get hurt all the time and it
was just [ __ ] see on the Main Street
it was just straight and I'd like 2530
pubs people swim pub to pub to pub to
pub and about five deep into the pubs
that's where all the fights would start
you know and we were just drunk and
being tough and it was like different
sets of people looking back it was a
[ __ ] gang there were gangs but we
never realized that that group their
dicks well we don't like that group and
that group doesn't like us and you know
by the end it was stupid childish [ __ ]
you know but like bottles and Paul
Hughes yeah all that stuff I've never
made a person bleed you know if I like a
bloody nose like a little bit of a fat
lip but I'd never like been in a fight
where like me and my friends were
beating somebody else
so much that were they really bleeding
from their head and we're just still
going yeah that situation but I beliefs
is that a good friend of mine has said
something or done something where I'm
like [ __ ] this guy's the real deal I had
two or three friends thrown up when we
were doing that that [ __ ] that we were
down and attack those [ __ ] hairy
dudes Oh get that dick so I don't never
forget we were chasing a guy when land
guy was a really dear friend of mine
looked at me and he goes I got a knife
I'm gonna cut him I'll never forget that
and he was dead serious
Wow I had to pull him off to get started
let me cut him just one time and I was
like Jesus Christ I'm hanging out with
damaged goods but he's my brother what
am I gonna do yeah what are you gonna do
yeah that's an interesting point it's
that's why I tell people you know the
Aven were you dealing with I have always
said this like in the UFC I think I
think somebody who could kill somebody
Carlos Condit hey hey hey let me tell
you a story about Carlos come there and
I've told you a bunch of times on the
podcast and one though I went out to
Afghanistan myself you write Faber
Carlos Condit BJ Penn but crazy [ __ ]
happened flying all around the little
air the fobs the fort's operational
bases high up in the mountains of
Afghanistan some of we started off at
Bagram which is like a huge base which
is crazy because they're out there at a
warzone but it's like it's like a
[ __ ] town you get massage there's
tanning booths Dairy Queen Burger King
the the big bases are [ __ ] legit
excuse me but the fobs are in the middle
of nowhere there might be like you know
ten fifteen people special forces in
like a small tiny camp and we were going
around to those places on a Blackhawk
helicopter just you know me and them
whatever a few places we did some
training with them and we're up high in
the mountains as I said the Special
Forces you know find a [ __ ] war in
Afghanistan so you know tough dudes
mentally you know but we're professional
fighters and they're a boxing ring and
in the little makeshift gym they had but
there were
a little boxing ring and they wanted to
spar that's part one they said you want
to spar on my yeah [ __ ] it you know I'm
gonna said no I'm not a [ __ ] but the
guy was cool he was cool
you know so we put gloves on he just
took it real like nice and easy was a
respectful guy you know and he was like
yeah that's cool we shook hands we had a
little sweat real nice
then this other guy said all right
Carlos you want to go and cuz yeah yeah
oh good and need to get in the ring and
the guy says to Carla's how hard we're
gonna go and Carla says well I'll hit
you as hard as you hit me which I
thought was a [ __ ] beautiful answer
and the guy was an [ __ ] because
straight after that bang punch Carlos in
the face as hard as he [ __ ] could
dropped him dropped it drop cars cars
got up shook it off went forward jab
right hand left high kick out cold
through the ropes like this knocked him
out cold but it was like he just the
look in his eye you know when he did it
and I was like yeah probably not the
smartest thing to do [ __ ] they've all
got weapons we're out in a [ __ ]
there's about 15 of them up in the mines
I forget of Afghanistan we could
disappear pretty easily so perhaps we
want to get out of here but back to your
point exactly 100% there's people that
take it easier than nice people and
there's people than that and people
never know it's like I always think
about OJ didn't know I didn't [ __ ] up
you know John McCarthy had a great
explanation of loj that he had that [ __ ]
that football players had only in
reverse CT CT that's why what do you
mean in Reverse etz I can make him it
made him lash out you know and made him
wash out yeah
and he kept it under control like I've
been watching that thing on FX because
you're on the road you mean it was like
a ticking time bomb waiting to explode I
think the cops got called to the house
yeah they weren't there he was he got in
trouble to console oh no no the cops got
called to the house it is in three years
the number is astronomical I don't want
to repeat it because I don't want to
look like an [ __ ] but if it was watch
they want they want about people versus
OJ Simpson
when the tape got leaked but the I guess
you know his record you've been here
before yeah oh yeah nobody knows a
ticking time-bomb
just like I knew I [ __ ] knew he's
beating up a woman's homeless a woman's
been shot for five days before he kill
really yeah like it's pretty interesting
there so she's kind of an [ __ ] for
bringing Ron Goldman around then cuz she
knew what the [ __ ] was going on Ron
Zobel was a coke delivery really is that
really what do I say they found out
years later Mezzaluna was just a coke
dealer that was at a restaurant and he
watched he lords of his mitral ass CBC
the article it was a big time I moved
out here as that [ __ ] was going on and I
met a girl and she told me that he
wasn't drunk when was the last time you
went to a restaurant lift your glass and
they came back and gave us the house
either he was [ __ ] her but he wasn't
[ __ ] of it she was waiting for Marcus
Allen dick Marcus Allen's Bangla and he
was just dropping off a coke package
they never found I smart of being and
when this whole trial was going on I was
just annoyed it was like 12 and I just
put that my mom was [ __ ] just so
engaged with that was good a WWF event I
remember and we were late because my mom
just was glued to court TV this is the
court see this was the first this like
opened up that whole category of like
reality television it was like real
world in the OJ Simpson trial kind of
like made everyone like so last night in
bed I was watching some show that Tom
Hanks produced on Netflix called the 90s
right and it's pretty good pretty good
yeah yeah yeah it's interesting and the
OJ Simpson trial it plays a part of it
part of what happened in the 90s and
they go into details but growing up in
England obviously it wasn't quite a
submerge into our culture for you guys
as it was for you guys of course it was
on the news we heard about it but we you
know for one I was younger so I didn't
really give a [ __ ] and nobody watches
American football in English so no one
really had an idea who it was but after
watching that last night and of course
I've seen the show and I've seen
documentaries and stuff I know how big
of a deal it was but it wasn't the same
inning that no one really cared it was
just another criminal lawsuit you know
yeah yeah it was it was such a it was
everything I mean I was in sixth grade
maybe I don't know seventh grade they
wheeled in TVs
for the day they gave him at the verdict
it was like the end of the school year
was like June or something it must have
been and they wheeled in TVs and the
teachers stopped giving a [ __ ] they're
like we're not teaching today we're just
watching this and you just heard the
classroom split it was crazy the
teachers would be cheering or like
screaming curse words based off it
because ever this was also the first
story that sort of split America like my
mom was so Pro a Jason it was bizarre my
mom was like Oh didn't do it that was
that she was on his side you know the
glove doesn't fit you must have quit my
mom was an idiot I don't understand the
glove thing well I was lucky kind of wit
I mean if I if my life depended on it
and I was gonna go to prison for a long
[ __ ] time
give me a glove if I could like make my
hands be seem a bit bigger believe it
doesn't go on like no [ __ ] stop
spreading your fingers so much and push
in the palm of your hand out you know if
my laughs see we are good just all right
won't go on J was guilty but he was the
Yankees plan against the high school
baseball team it was that type of
payroll again sighs who been here and
there was dirty [ __ ] that we're not the
lawyer the cops did dirty [ __ ] and they
created all this reasonable doubt yes
they raised the reason that was it yeah
I saw the show it was brilliant about it
that that John Travolta yes that's the
one I'm watch it's not [ __ ] awesome
oh so good the acting in night increment
it really is have you ever seen that I
didn't see it it's on it's on left wait
you gotta check it out it's an awesome
piece tremendous they really television
work he's incredible it really is
exploited like what was going on there
was like you know five or six heavy-duty
[ __ ] attorneys all over me goes yeah
yeah yeah everybody's a [ __ ] mean
nobody ever knew the name of an attorney
before the OJ trial Marcia Clark [ __ ]
I always had heard about the one guy
Johnny Cochran you know the white guy
yeah how good is that
John Chabal you know he's he's does that
good facial expressions and stuff
incredible brilliant as that guy he
really was it was a weird time you know
like the Rodney King bird
this red radish was that's what you saw
last night was that we got that all
sparklers the Rodney King verdict what's
the Rodney King rod beginning I weren't
here none of this [ __ ] was a black
guy who got pulled over I mean I've
heard the name you know I yeah I've
heard of Russell guy from his balcony
tape the cops just playing ping-pong oh
really
ah [ __ ] yeah the tape got leaked which
Friday night first please video all
lived in Simi Valley right the cops so
they all got acquitted and downtown LA
went crazy right I'm gonna figure out I
was doing comedy in the Chinese
restaurant and the guy's name was Ron
and I would torment Ron I would tell him
I was gonna bring Cosby and all these
big names and get money up front and go
buy cocaine and [ __ ] that's how that's
why I'm here yeah there was times I
would bring girls in there and hang like
a big shower
where's Robin Ron give us all around the
drinks pulled out my own Cosby's coming
don't worry about my time the whole
thing and that's what we watched where
they were forget this way they pulled
the white dial half the truck yeah and
they hit him in the head with a brick on
national TV I mean it was crazy it was
never helicopter view you watch those
nature videos where you see like the
line about to kill like a deer somebody
help the deer and nobody does that's
what it was watching it from the
helicopter just [ __ ] yeah it's insane
you know cuz I'm so much more aware of
racism since I've moved to this country
there's no black people on Elland well
well yeah there was no black people grow
where I grew up
no no not down in London there's a
massive you know black community it's a
very multi Commerce City and there's
there's a very big Middle Eastern
influence you know in the Indians of
Pakistanis but there was no black guys
but where I'm from it's a small town out
in the country and it's predominantly
all white you know all white and if it's
a wound so we had no preconceived ideas
or any judgments against somebody could
do another color you know what I mean
for me it didn't exist whatsoever
there's going to be standing at another
boy
I remember like you know I like in like
the 90s if people start saying you see
that today they were like what a black
guy walking through the town centre Bold
As Brass
you know just didn't get in it but then
that as like the world gets a smaller
place yeah you know more and more
different cultures started coming to the
town you know so yeah I didn't grow up
experience any of this what you're
talking about
of course in the big cities in London
Manchester Birmingham place like that of
course but I'm from a small town just
outside of there you know and Barry
lived a very segregated lifestyle didn't
leave there until I was older you know
that's very interesting you say those
very racist here no I'm not saying it's
very racist as to what I'm saying I'm
saying I'm aware that racism culture
more since I've moved here
you know I sent it you heard on the news
there's issues you hear about you know
in politics and stuff you know it's
another time because also I'm getting
older
yeah well so so I'm maturing as a person
you realise yeah you travel the world
more and use social media started
exploding you know that was probably
around the time when you moved to what
your movie this it's a 2011 yeah dude I
mean that's like the the explosion of
social media culture at the turn of 2010
I was insane it was more races here than
race than it is in England because it
probably is racism exist yeah 100% it
does yeah yeah there's big problems in
London you know in the cities of course
well up and down the country now as I
says the black or white why I'm black
[Applause]
there's a lot of racial tension in
England with the Muslim communities the
Muslim you know Pakistanis there's a lot
of there's a lot of tension there you
know there really is I've gotta put my
words carefully because you know I don't
wanna offend anybody at all you know but
yeah there's a lot of racial change
Michael Bisping doesn't want to offend
anybody
I don't you know Muslim Jewish Christian
whatever the [ __ ] you are I think you're
all idiots right you know so you know as
long as you're good to me I'm good to
you yeah dude you know it's uh I I think
it's very strange like I think we put so
much like we demonize racism so much but
then we want Michelle we yeah but then
we watch people like I was at a Yankees
game a couple weeks I don't give a [ __ ]
about sports at all but I want to the
Yankees game I from y'all should be
already tickets and he was like do you
want come you know great sure and there
was a guy who walked by an Oakland A's
head can't do that in the playoffs dude
why do you keep talking about things I
don't nothing about Ron dicks you know
everyone and now baseball been with Ron
what was his name the guy in the boot
the guy had the guy the cops would be
what the [ __ ] oh it's so and now
baseball the guy in the Oakland A's has
walked by and then 2000 people waiting
to get into Yankee Stadium as guys
welcome by girls
I joined in I loved it it was the
greatest it was so much fun but what's
the difference he's just wearing a
[ __ ] green hat well it's not it's not
really like hood it's a choice I like
that about sports to be honest and
violent I can enjoy soccer stadium logic
gets crazy
you have no idea exactly it's sort of
holiday it's the same thing it's just a
color of a shirt or a territory where
you're from it's sort of in the same say
celebrate that type of you know it's not
racism we should we celebrate it we kind
of call it's funny right but what's
really difference between like some 60
year old dude being like yeah you know
I'd be really upset of my daughter
married a black guy that's sort of
that's way less damaging than a [ __ ]
soccer riot there's way less people hurt
yeah but there's a clip of a Red Sox fan
throwing a pizza slice and hitting a
Yankee fan in the face at Fenway Park
and I watch that whenever I get set
I'm with you if you sports and you just
busting each other's balls but what if
it was a Chinese guy it was like a
[ __ ] throws a pizza in his face
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] you know but it's
just a friendly sports thing and it's
banter you know some all right maybe
sometimes it crosses the line you know a
lot of the times [ __ ] me you know I even
in the 80s in the 90s with the football
hooligans well you know it wasn't a good
place for the sport but but a friendly
bit of ball busting over whatever the
[ __ ] team jersey wearing no no no no
no no listen let me explain something to
you I'm not talking about bit I'm
literally talking about busting their
ball right here really I don't mean
here's a society we live in if you gonna
hand me my Dodger Stadium a couple of
years ago they beat a man into a coma
yeah for having a giant what they used
to do like this guy from our town they
did like the famous namely they got set
down for a while
they knew the Train from the Blackburn
fans was coming past on the train tracks
so they [ __ ] stopped the train by
cause that's something on the train
tracks they stopped the trains train out
to stop cause it barricaded the tracks
you ran into the tray and all of them
beat the [ __ ] out of all of them oh yeah
yeah yeah so I'm well aware of what goes
down and it was kind of the story is
just kind of uh you know that's kind of
great yeah hey watch the movies on
Netflix the football [ __ ] to it great
check it out so grins all about Dan's
blog Green Street hood football [ __ ]
it's hilarious it's like soccer in it
yeah yeah the football fight wanna be
informed check it out man it's great and
I says I've always like I'm the type of
guy I watch the Sunday football game and
you have a jersey on and your team's
losing 21 not true you deserve to get
beat up before the jersey that's the
school of thought like you sitting there
like an [ __ ] your team's dying 31
nothing in my world you deserve a
beating for wearing that shirt you're 31
years old we're gonna like eat
somebody's [ __ ] just sitting there
with a jersey on I don't have a [ __ ]
jersey in - okay what else pisses me off
when I see fat people with football
jerseys
it drives me up a [ __ ] war like a
400-pound doing
for poor Jersey does me [ __ ] crazy
what's the hair like you you dis way
because you disrespecting the football
jersey you fat [ __ ] you them saying I
get off the plane their day there's a
guy 500 pound Dodgers shirt on take it
off if I'm a Dodger I tell them here's
the 50 bucks take it off you're too big
you can't be disrespected whatever but
that's the [ __ ] I hate about sports I
went to a giant Philly football game at
Giants that no I'm lying to you freely
jet football game at Giants Stadium in
93 and some guy walked down with a Miami
Dolphin his jacket and a guy like
Michael Bisping went up to him politely
and said excuse me
do us a favor so you'll all feel at home
[Laughter]
the guy goes [ __ ] you man I said okay
have a nice day and he turned around he
went at all of us I had things started
to get thrown at this guy I mean they
were throwing everything first it
started with like pretzels and sauces
and then it just shoes are tricks and
the people around them and then you know
the dude does he gets up and turns
around and goes [ __ ] you know they're
just throwing [ __ ] at him I mean
everything at least I keep it up [ __ ]
you we're gonna win you know what a
dolphin jacket on you had a jet silly
game wearing teal in Jersey then looking
sad [ __ ] those guys in Jersey trained
for that should all we go after he got
hit so much security had to come with
like a shield and they're getting [ __ ]
thrown at him as he's walking out I mean
it was classic that's great the guy was
drenched in [ __ ] and is that necessary
a giant stadium or Philly state it's not
bad though that's just a finish throwing
some shed them I'm making fun of them I
actually think that's pretty tame you
know I mean well the thing that bothers
me is when people change like you're
supposed to like where you're from or at
best maybe your parents are from there
I'll allow that but people who just move
and change like what would happen
never change football teams or may if
you don't like football II does that
like in the UK can you you can't just
change teams I mean I was never the
biggest sports guy so I'm not the best
guy TV chocolate change cultures he's a
sellout he's a [ __ ] Californian now I
get shaped for the way I talk every day
I've never felt myself have been so
self-conscious about my accent as to
what I am in this room really these
[ __ ] axe is going every time I speak
I got the headphones on I hear Mary
Poppins [ __ ] chatting away in the
corner but still even saying that to
Americans supposed to English part of me
they're like what's with the [ __ ]
American accent my what why are you
talking like that because I want to be
understood that's why I flunked America
if you wanted to no way I mean I come
you know if I might you whatever do a
little bit gap yeah yeah I'm gonna be
judged
let's hear Texas it's crazy huh awesome
Batman say again the guy that played
Batman
Christian Bale Christian but it's
[ __ ] incredible dad somebody
syllables a Christian that would say go
though Christian Christian my friend did
the fighter with him he says I don't
even know he was English till the
premiere yeah oh really
yeah yeah I premiered and though he was
English she kept this [ __ ] accent and
you know Jax teller you know he's my guy
for Sons of Anarchy oh sure of course
yes
I had no idea until recently did some
other movies they read the Madonna's
husband was the director when I saw him
on a talk show cuz he was promoting the
movie and I was at this [ __ ]
English I had no that's how good I had
no idea he [ __ ] up a little bit in the
sun's a hand right okay metal watch Sons
of Anarchy toxicology but I don't get
the hard guys it's good shot at watching
it I'm two episodes in a month
turn it off no it's it's not an Academy
of would win it but you watch it for the
writing yeah the guy does it great he
weaves it I felt the same way about the
wire which apparently by all accounts
he's fantastic I haven't got past two or
three yet but I'm with you bro I smell I
wash I go into it wanting to like it
with a open mind
I love it you sell by order he was
amazing the best TV you've ever seen
he's British by the way orders Elba I
know it the language is so thick like
the cop talk though it's hard to follow
I think half the problem is I'm watching
it with my wife Jesus Oh Michael this is
terrible why are we watching this you
know cuz why truce but I haven't got
past ya racist they're they're hardcore
yeah call get past the first call I
gotta go back and try it again because I
see the way you always look at it was
upset right now like the wire no I
thought the waterfall cow I thought the
wire was a good show it just wasn't one
of my favorites yeah I think it was
what's your favorite show ever Joey
favorite television show of all time
that's a that's a tough one it's never
my answer
okay go ahead what's yours game of
[ __ ] yeah I'm gonna say that's one of
mine I thought I think it's the best
when you consider all things considered
the violence the favorite Thrones
Sopranos Breaking Bad top three my shows
are The Honeymooners is number one
number two is The Sopranos
number three is I don't even know
[ __ ] Game of Thrones is so act I'm
waiting for it to be over
I haven't started it yet what well
you're a [ __ ] if I tell you something
you're not gonna believe this please I
love everything from England I love the
music you know everything I listen to
you know the whole movement to be those
the whole [ __ ] deal I cannot watch a
whole movie would have English accents
my hearing kids break it contact it
especially when they talk too fast like
snatch I could tolerate you know cuz
they keep saying bloody [ __ ] and I like
that they use the word every time you
may see some great movies Joey I've
heard my wife watches and I sit and
watch 15 minutes here is what I think
you're like sexy beast
oh I've seen that yeah no I watched them
I'm a professional I'm straight I'm a
[ __ ] professional if something
I
just there's a lot of movies sure I know
a lot of things in Spanish I can't
tolerate like your dad put the [ __ ]
whatever on the ozarks on the plane I
love the others I had hit the wrong
button
so was it Spanish so I'm like why they
talking so much [ __ ] Spanish for the
cartel plays a big part of this entire
race both episodes and I go let me see
if Tyson I put the movie Tyson on cuz I
downloaded that and that's in Spanish
and I go what the [ __ ] is going on with
my [ __ ] iPad I figured out where they
get the Spanish over when I felt bad cuz
I believe the ozarks yeah because I
watch all those [ __ ] Spanish shows on
at Netflix I watch you know Darko's and
then this one that's Jota Jota that was
Pablo Escobar's the born killer I'm a
bad Porto Rican I'm sick of speak
English already Jesus no I you speak
Spanish Louis I can leave I've never
asked you that like seven things yeah
that's it
I can I mean I'm so bad I miss speaking
Spanish so I watched that I lived
through it yeah like I liked when I was
a kid going to the Bronx after my mother
died and eating Puerto Rican food
because for one an hour we get to talk
Spanish you know every when you deal
with Puerto Ricans when you first meet
him you have to ask him for that
blessing if they're older than you are I
always thought that was a beautiful
thing when I was growing up where if I
saw with Michael Bay even though Michael
business is the UFC champion of the
world if he sees me and I have white
hair he's gotta go
I mean this young and I'll go after
India that means God bless you
I learned that from the poor so I would
just go that's nice that's good I will
go and I wish war old you like that
around these days cuz the world is going
[ __ ] top seat everyone I always
believed that so I would go up there
just to get that type of Spanish II
respect when I put my daughter in this
preschool at first I went to a bunch of
preschools I put her in the school boy
to Spanish when I'm working because I
don't think no [ __ ] you were talking
about your girlfriend before I dated one
Spanish girl in high school I'm Spanish
and after that I knew hmm they were not
for me it's not a good name it's it's
hard
I think the Catholic Church have a
similar thing don't they with the altar
boys in the priests let's go if you want
like rocky when he goes to the priest
and the ask them for a blessing that is
it's great in American traditions but
some Italians will always say like
somebody needs you
yeah you have to say something back then
that means God bless you know he's a
little older than you or whatever I'm
not the [ __ ] topic was [ __ ] but are
you Catholic were you raised Catholic I
was raised as a Catholic yeah who's
their big Catholic population massive
yeah massive yeah for sure yeah more
Protestant Church of England but yeah
yeah big Catholic populated my mum's
Irish like full-on Irish not like you
know American say they're Irish my mom
was born in Ireland the dad was a
preacher about 15 brothers and sisters
so a Catholic family and then my dad was
in the Army serving in Northern Ireland
when the war was on I met my mom so that
was a whole scandal to do so yeah so
yeah so we're Catholic
it's pretty [ __ ] interesting yeah
yeah and is that do they have the same
pedophilia problem we have over here
with those yeah Wow I mean I've never
experienced it thank God it's worldwide
yeah I don't think it's a it's not an
American thing it's just you know it's a
Catholic Church but as I say I'm not a
religious person so yeah you get in
trouble all the time for like not
[ __ ] on a religion you just like you
know it's because people care about
religion it's [ __ ] up because the
reality is 99.9 percent of the time
they're really good people and then if
they're trying to live their lives as
you know by the the tenets of the
religion they're probably doing good for
themselves and their family but and when
you should on that if let me tell you
this here in America you guys I say you
guys are mean new Americans part of me
and people of America and I don't mean
that in a insulting way are obsessed
with religion in England I was talking
about this last night I took my wife
would let him bed u7h and I'm like no
and I said this to a producer of Fox
recently and she didn't believe me she's
that uh no that's just your friends
I don't know a single person in England
that goes to church not a single [ __ ]
person nobody nobody goes to church
nobody talks about church only time they
go to church to get married a
christening or a funeral and that's it
no one goes to church maybe that's why
they're all closing down maybe there's
some really old ladies or whatever you
know my wife still goes to church
religiously every Sunday yeah a lot of
people do they go to church I'm Catholic
so I stick to my roots if the kid sings
in the choir I'll put a suit on and go
down there for the day but besides great
what the [ __ ] are you actually believe
in God I believe in something if you
live the life I lived you got to believe
in something
yeah something's out there something
more powerful than its why is it I don't
know I don't know know everybody has
their own I don't I don't but I do
debate it from time yeah I'm sure and
this is what I always say I'm sure it's
a great feeling and I wish I wish it was
a higher power out there and I wish that
if I got on my [ __ ] knees and prayed
hard enough that good things would
happen but I don't I wish I did you know
by for the most part kiddos used to
myself and I respect everyone's
religions is on that's great and more
power to you and respect but don't try
and compare me but as using right we
both done sales in our life and then we
think we connected with like early when
I met you when we talked about that was
like I almost feel like that's the same
thing right like if you believe that God
is on your [ __ ] side and you really
believe that right and you truly believe
it will affect is a real thing well it's
yourself it's assuming the sale
it's your suit you're going if you
really believe that it's gonna happen
it's more than likely it's gonna happen
you got to carry yourself a certain way
if you believe it's already happened you
believe you're gonna get a boot carry
yourself like Conor McGregor right now
he's out there carried himself like he
didn't lose it the weekend he's acting
like a winner he's running out on the
[ __ ] Dallas Cowboys field throwing
footballs around proper 12 whiskey it
was like a couple of weeks from now no
one remembers you carry yourself in that
way yeah and if any of you religious and
something good happens you think that's
[ __ ] God
it's just not her you you put your sort
of faith into I would raise catholic
cuban catholic that the cubit is a very
strong Irish Catholic like the Irish in
1614 the Battle of boy the Irish that
didn't want to fight in fact went to
Cuba because it was the ovary of the
Catholic can I tell you something not
for nothing I got 26% reefer over there
why you smoking that garbage in my
office
I got 26% reefer over there that'll kill
Emile and it's nothing that percent
water vapor with that [ __ ] killer to
come on when you wake up you can't see
good [ __ ] Joey say no good [ __ ] not
going over there that's the [ __ ] that
killed John McCain and you're smoking
that pile let me guess John McCain I
would love it
it's called ghost OG get the bomb call
are gonna take you know guys I'm a weak
[ __ ] I leave the box
ghost og ya know means I'm good yeah you
hit that vapor don't do that before you
what am i doing what am i no no I don't
know if he wants there's a container
you're talking about things that might
kill you that bong that's the warmth I
five still I knew you wanted the bomb
glad I didn't want to touch it get the
clothes right here that looks like he
could kill ya yeah I gotta tell you
something okay
I was raised Catholic me check that my
mother died at 16 and I told God to suck
my dick because a God would not take a
parent from the child but then I went to
the University I lived in Boulder and
when I went to Boulder he used to hang
out at this place called Naropa
Institute and it's a Buddhist college
it's an accredited Buddhist College
where kids will have a lot of money and
major in philosophy they go there so I
could talk make-believe this smart or
whatever I took a couple classes there
but then I learned about something
Michael Bisbee go on that was more
powerful than any Bible could teach me I
learned about Karma absolutely the
things I did will always come back to me
and for the example like when I
kidnapped a dude I made $18,500 you know
how much my attorney bill was eighteen
thousand dollars so for the happiest of
my life I made
500 hours you know I've had different
situations like that where karma has
come back and bit me in the ass so maybe
I don't never believe in God or whatever
I do believe there's something out there
I do believe that you know I lost a
child I lost a child when I was 30 I
took a choice to do comedy and my wife
doesn't let me talk to that kid no more
so all of a sudden I stopped doing blow
again my life to go I stopped robbing
people and somebody some Hindu god or
whatever lakhs of my wife who smoke more
weed than me how can I even have sperm
cells
Harvin says if you smoke dope you get no
sperm cells I never knock somebody up I
[ __ ] 50 bang [ __ ]
now and shot loads and everybody I
didn't you before when I was like this
like a dick I shout loads and everybody
just on principle and I never be was a
myth no I never yeah I never not nobody
up and all of a sudden I knock this poor
woman up when I'm 50 [ __ ] years old
so I've gotten signs Michael bismi I
don't know who it is or what it is I'm
of he's Chinese and well Charles Bronson
I don't know who the [ __ ] it is but this
is me in my world do I go to church on
Sunday you know Stephen Fry's clock no
if I said you something late can you
play it
I've got a link here oh [ __ ] yeah
basically this guy Stephen Fry he used
to be a comedian is very very smart guy
English guy and on the video he's
sitting with a priest and it's a big
deal priest or whatever and probably
getting some things wrong and he's a
hard a theist Stephen Fry's very well
known for it kind of like Ricky Gervais
same shape and they said if you died and
went to heaven and you were confronted
by God what would you say to him then
and he said brain cancer in children
really and he went through all these
things and he said there's an insect out
there that sole purpose in life is to
bore it only into the children and into
babies eyeballs that's that that's only
babies their sole purpose in life when
they're born in some weird [ __ ]
country somewhere they're our sole
purpose is to find babies and burrow and
go into the eyes and kill them why would
you make them you know it's a
fascinating video and say and he puts
this this preachers in the house a
[ __ ] answer
there's no what to say but if you google
for anyone listening Stephen Stephen Fry
explains what he would say if he
confronted yes it's right that's not why
I don't believe in God this is really
good yeah I don't know if God sitting up
there he's got angels around I can't
tell you that I just know for some
reason just the situations that I've
been involved that there's something out
there something great what how I have no
[ __ ] idea yeah I uh I have no idea
it's weird
I have a hard time I have a hard time
believing it's anything spiritual I
believe there's something out there
on a physical level I believe that in
other universes we have really powerful
[ __ ] aliens that are like able to do
crazy [ __ ] that we're nowhere near like
and maybe one day you can advance
civilized way yeah I mean we're the only
to millions and millions of light-years
away yes millions of galaxies awareness
that has to be really the size of the
universe unless they're out of the mind
there has to be there must be because we
live in the sweet spot that's what they
call it right not too close not too far
away from the Sun where I'll just warm
enough or not cold enough for life to
evolve and all those [ __ ] there's
literally I don't know how they know
this stuff but there's some
mathematicians or whatever whatever XY
space there's millions of millions if
not billions of planets that are in the
sweet spot of this Sun so you know it's
just down to when you put it like that
of course these are the life out there I
believe it's like there's that and I
believe that there's I just I I believe
when you die that's the end of the life
cycle AJ I just believe it's like but
it's weird because I haven't lost too
many people I'm lucky but people start
to die a lot but as of right now I
haven't experienced too much death I
haven't but my dog died
I don't know this sounds insulting to
anybody lost my dear my dog died last
year you know that is weird
Oh God it affects him to this day
[ __ ] died when I was filming a movie
I was in between Tate
and I get a phone call from my wife I've
got to give the OL care to put my dog
down I went back to [ __ ] set to do
the next scene now I'm supposed to be a
badass that's just blowing a [ __ ]
Billy job scene where you had a crime
it's Trevor I were going after dude it's
over there what I'm saying is though I
don't believe in God and this and that
but I tell you what I was sat in the
back of the car having a beer with a
little chair streaming down my face and
thinking to myself if you're up there if
you are up there if your soul is up
there do you throw this one's for you
buddy
you know and it's where your mind goes
to that space to look for some kind of
comfort you know because because we're
told from an early age when were born
that it is there maybe I'm the ignorant
one for doubting that so maybe just in
case I'm wrong hmm what somebody take
care of my dog yeah I know you guys you
flew in tonight and I know you've lived
in town you know you live a little walk
far away so I don't want to keep you
guys unless you might open up that door
no Joey how I got but for the last week
people been asking me for a recap of the
UFC and since I'm not a fighter and so
many people did recap so 229 I didn't do
one but now since you guys are here and
Michael's a professional likes champion
and he said something that was very
interesting you got beat up a week ago
you know the biggest one of the things
that I listened to khabib saying was he
was gonna humble hmm you know yet and
I've been humbled in my life and you
have handcuffs on and the judge says
four years boy do you get humble like a
[ __ ] you know when somebody puts
a gun to your head you get humble
there's so many times you know let's
break down to 29 what you saw what I saw
the Lewis song well Louis J [ __ ]
you're the only person I swear to god
I've never corrected you and I would
never there's something there is there
is you're right he has a present there's
something about John that anybody else
in the world that would [ __ ] correct
but not Joey Diaz I mean what do you
want me to do you want me to break down
the final I just yeah like her dad
millions for me it was I I knew Tony
Ferguson was gonna win I just had a
funny feeling he wasn't coming back I
love surgery I love Duke Rufus nothing
against I just he thought it was a bit
too much for Sir
Joe and I like there's a lock Lee knows
I don't bet the last time I bet was
McGregor Diaz one because he flinched at
the weigh-in who you bet on
I bet on dear oh you did yeah because
McGregor flinched at the weigh-in
anything move and he didn't move and
then the second one I didn't bet someone
did that to me recently well you got
balls of steel he can't to the side wow
that said not one of the watches resign
along the watch this fighters a fan yeah
but when I found out that kabhi was a
favorite
Tyler was an underdog it made me very
curious because I come from a backward
sports gambling background and I know
how to read lines
I've been burnt too much by lines once
you get burned by lines you know how to
read them and that line told me wait a
second so Connors gonna knock this guy
out just like that and America's gonna
win money on kind of McGregor Regan's
doesn't work like that so that was the
first hint of a rap but then I
discovered that there was an over and
under and that's a completely different
game his people would have just bet the
under and gone to sleep
you could have bet Tony Ferguson and
gone to sleep and not watch the fight
call the book any with a pager the next
day that's how confident I was about
Ferguson I didn't feel that confident
about McGregor but I
I thought McGregor could pull some
mother hat but then he said two things
number one he showed up with the whiskey
and number two he said something very
interesting and I caught these words she
says if you haven't seen the videos
they're on McGregor production company
video nobody takes the time to say that
all those things they take time out of
your [ __ ] day what strength all those
things take time out of your day then I
waited for the Wayne I I saw the New
York City thing and between you guys
it was the residual of something he was
just talking just I don't even know was
coming on when he pulled out the vodka
bottle there was something that
you know they said that John Jones
tested for cocaine before a fight I'm
waiting for a test result to come back
yeah because he was acting very cocaine
at the New York press conference and
then at the weigh-in when he went to
push his hand and he saw that Ivan
Drago's hand and move once 50 people
were around him he got tough and he drew
that little half of thanks I said it was
the worst kick I ever seen in my life
when I'm 10 feet away the kid didn't
react him
the kid was mentally prepared the kid
didn't even understand what the [ __ ] he
was saying at the time that's what he
had his defense right he did not even
know and whenever he would open up his
now he doesn't know enough English to
protect himself not to that extent
you know so all those things factored in
I wouldn't tell him cause he's the kiss
of death I wanted to see what he liked
because if he liked somebody you're dead
mmm don't lose automatically what did
you like in the fight well I honestly
didn't know I had I've seen a couple I
gave their fights a lot lately victim
Invicta chick no I've been on khabib I
also saw Tanya Avenger would go over 1
and a half yeah you found that that
don't [ __ ] happen but it was all
those things came every will effect so I
reached out to a friend of mine who was
taking some action and I just blasted
him yeah oh really I got the over from I
just blasted and I thought about it and
thought about that oh you never seen it
boogie with a part-time job
yeah it's just not gonna work out you
know it's not gonna so what was your bet
I had the over at three rounds not two
and a half on most people at it I had it
at three rounds and kebede so could be a
winner yeah and can be wins at pyramid
you put a lot of money nano could be we
act a beam in the over tan jelly a
nickel on me it's just I wondered yeah
just to just to take a check 500 I don't
bet with my wife and you did a parlay no
I bet them straight parlays a sucker's
bet
really yeah I was a parlay I was just
safe par like every time that's a safe
parlay but it could have been a safe
ball
McGregor Kobe's gonna take him down in
the first round
yeah I I think there was a chance I took
Kirby would stretch him out but I also
put there was a chance we could beep
take him down in the first round that
was like if you would have put gun to my
head what's gonna happen that a fight I
would have said could be with the
decision but you know once again Connery
was always gonna win that fight yeah but
he's a once-in-a-lifetime type of
fighter Conor like he does create those
moments so it wouldn't have been crazy
if we woke up that I said kinda knocked
him out and [ __ ] $0.32 no it wouldn't
have been crazy it wouldn't it was
always gonna win them yeah and Daniel oh
I picked Conor to win on the Fox Sports
thing out on our long story as to why I
did that but a guy like that strike
against a wrestler a wrestle of khabib
level unfortunately I hate to say cuz my
backgrounds are striker but a wrestler
of that level will always be a striker
and the reason why I'm could be dropped
him in the second round and started
getting the better of him on the feet is
because and I've been there myself
you're so [ __ ] concerned with the
wrestling okay you lie if I throw a
punch
they're gonna come underneath it they're
gonna come in and grab my legs and use
like do I do a throat punch and you
start getting super timid insensitive
and then all of a sudden you're waiting
for a takedown boom you get [ __ ]
blasted in the face cuz you're thinking
about the takedown and you're waiting
for it and you're waiting for it and
then you get punched in the face you
know and that's what happened on
Saturday night that's why he got dropped
in the third round
that's why a rematch will probably go
the same way because now not only did he
have the physical and skillset
advantages he's also now got the win
against him already
you got the psychological advantage so
yeah that fight was always gonna go down
that way in my humble opinion I for some
people's for some reason people think I
don't like her I like her
I think Connors a great compelling he's
a great fighter he's taken down some
great names but I also knew there was
holes and again I'm a fat [ __ ] but I did
everything growing up I did everything
growing up everything five years ago I
walked into a jujitsu studio and they
made me do a hip escape
have a heart attack and I walked out of
that studio and I go I'll never go to
jiu-jitsu training ever again and then
two blocks away I said why not
I might [ __ ] a pool what's the
problem it's just and I would have
anxiety on my back and I kept going back
but something happened along the way I
acquired the respect for how long it
takes to be a black belt in jujitsu
takes a long [ __ ] time you got to do
a lot of things so Wendy as for kind of
the first time that's what I kept
thinking about how hard it is to be a
black belt especially in that school
ways that were there animals there's
animals he's up there with Melendez and
Jake Shields and his brother and him
that's why I took him the first time the
second time I wasn't in Vegas so I
didn't bet it yeah you know this time I
just saw I saw a lot of holes in this
game I saw holes in his game well now
what the boxer when he fought the boxer
right there I said every trainer in MMA
should be bitch-slapped because he
nullified his left all that [ __ ] they
talked about his left he nullified it to
my science boxing is a science and all
my said I think that he carried him for
10 rounds between you and I
I was running out of cardio in the third
[ __ ] well that's what they said
that's what they said and again a lot of
people have the popular opinion that I
don't like Conor and we have the same
manager and we used to be canna poly
these days we don't talk but it's
whatever we're a stupid [ __ ] fall and
now you know changing people say are you
jealous of it you jealous of him let me
just say this right now still a single
[ __ ] man on this planet that I'm
jealous of very happy being me you know
I know it yeah no I'm not saying I have
issues and stuff but I've never in my
life looked at one person talk god I
wish I was him yes I was him
Connors a very very very good fighter
but you you said something before they
kind of got my attention and it made me
think I mean you know as far as me and
Connor comes from me you know he wasn't
born with a silver spoon in his mouth
from water and alcohols from a tough
area of Dublin right and in that two
years he's a fire so he fires any chalk
she
because he's from that neck of the woods
and he's that type of person I'm very
much the same way when you get some
success it changes everything like
Evander Holyfield said it's hard to get
up and run at 5:00 a.m. when you're
sleeping in silk sheets right things do
change but now with the whiskey right
that's an even bigger play cuz you know
as a fighter that always be remembered
he's definitely a legendary one of the
greats you know what he did he set the
world on fire
Chuck mixed martial arts to a new level
but that whiskey shed if he can get that
poppin properly five generations from
now they'll be talking about the
McGregor brand of whiskey the proper 12
Alinsky's horrific sold more bottles
this last weekend he already made it
he's not gonna get them for another
Bobby I don't know anything about
whiskey I can take off because of for
whatever reason then that's a legacy and
and and you know a level of money that
fighting would never bring you know what
I'm saying of course now I don't know
I'm Wishman it's very tough he's a very
welcome for you it's very yeah it's very
now I told you the beginning that comedy
and fighting it's an art so it turned
into the same when you Amy Schumer when
you Lewis CK when you're all those type
of comments you always have a target on
your back
mmm who did you steal from who did you
steal from why did you steal from you
sold the joke in 1992 everything comes
out you know and the same thing comes
out in fighting it's no [ __ ]
different you know for sure it's no
[ __ ] different so when hrodna started
getting busy if she got knocked out and
after the fight she was sitting there
you're thinking about all the time that
you [ __ ] around that you know that's
why I loved when Connor said I'm not
doing any press it's like us as comics
so I got a fly in it [ __ ] the night
before and then you want me to get up at
3:00 in the morning California time to
go into a radio and be tell jokes do
that three days in a row in the old days
we got a podcast that has wave not
and way more veggies way before the park
before about when you went into a tunnel
you get up three days in the road six
o'clock yeah even though you snorted
blow the night before even though you
ate the waitress [ __ ] whatever you
did the night before they picked you up
at 6:00 and you did radio till 12:00
went back to the hotel and then went
back at 3:30 that [ __ ] takes away from
you so it does and just like the success
in the fighting and everybody wanted a
piece of you you know wanted to go on
this team maybe this time eating
sponsors appearances signings checks
checks money when you come from a
background where you have to fight it's
hard to say no to that [ __ ]
which actually Colin did a very good job
of doing so certainly in this training
camp but like when I would the champ and
I was training to fight dan Henderson I
was in England filming a movie at the
same time I'm flying to Montenegro do
another [ __ ] in the weekends while still
training for a fight and I did still do
it I trained very hard but that's not
ideal the [ __ ] you know and that's
different because he was an older guy as
well do you know what I mean but if it
was a young [ __ ] up-and-comer they'd
be laughing thinking you know they'd be
at the gym at 6:00 a.m. they wouldn't be
doing all this I'm getting my training
in but in between film and a movie and
do another [ __ ] you know but it's the
the opportunities that come to you as a
champion they're hard to turn down and
for me I was toward the end of my career
so I was kind of thinking well I'm gonna
do all this stuff to set myself up so I
can walk away and also didn't sort of
the the media responsibilities it had to
have set you up for what you're doing
now which with 100 podcasting we did a
radio show for years yeah all the UFC
tonight [ __ ] you know you did so much
media I'm sure the first time you did an
interview with a microphone in front of
your face I would love to go I remember
it was Cage Rage 7 I think it was my
third ever MMA fight and you know they
do a little bit of Rahman they stick a
camera in your face and I'm like and as
I said a little town that I've talked
about still I didn't really I didn't
left there I'd never been to London you
know what I mean I was like I was a
small town boy and yet this would
Cameron
you know I'm [ __ ] he's my third fight
you know I didn't give a [ __ ] but Bobby
Lee was falsified their champion and he
and Babloo got injured and wasn't
fighting the right [ __ ] the champion
needs someone see they brought me in as
cannon fodder just to get beat up and I
went down and he said I had no idea how
big it was
I'd only fall into like two small sports
halls
next when I'm in London at Wembley Arena
which is like kind of a legendary place
Jesus and Jesus crazy yeah ya know I
[ __ ] up the other two guys pretty 30
seconds and they like people were
talking you know I'm like well bring
that northerner in bring him down here
it will [ __ ] him up and there's a camera
in my face and I'm like a frozen the lat
what do you want to say you want to send
him a message and he was like the the
worst delivery of worst line ever I
might well I just want to say good luck
cuz you're gonna need the most cliched
line ever just want to say yeah good
luck [ __ ] that's gonna need it that all
gay family how much to fight to have
before the u.s. see King Kong and so in
England the answer to that is none but
what what I did so I started martial
arts at 8 and I was obsessed with it and
I used to I started doing Japanese
jiu-jitsu which is you know they do
everything in Japanese Gigio martial
arts took something away from Japanese
jiu-jitsu and amplified it and made it
better so we did everything with the
grappling striking takedowns break balls
[ __ ] weapons numb choke swords you
name it we did everything and that's
what Japanese who is this fascinating
martial art and we started doing this
competition called knock down sport Budo
which my trainer my sensei should I say
organized and that was MMA but that term
MMA didn't exist but it was back there
no no gloves punches cakes takedowns
everything submissions and they were
like international tournaments and you
know I was fighting grown men at 15
years old from [ __ ] Sweden or
whatever in these tournaments and not
that small boot on and you know I win
them all and I never lost a martial art
tournament in my life as a kid you know
so I but then as I say got out of it and
started you know I'm being an ass on
hanging out and partying and the [ __ ]
third nipples call you got a bored of it
and that was I was 16 I was like [ __ ]
this you know battling to somebody and
all that [ __ ] I started partying and
doing all that stuff and then you know
then I wanted to make some money from a
I knew I could fight never you know they
had a lot of success in martial arts and
I was bit of a tall rag when I was a kid
I was you know I was always getting into
fights so I knew I could fight and then
someone told me there was money to be
made in the UFC so I was like well let's
give this a shot then and I said as I
said long story third fight there was
that at Wembley Arena one that with that
with the cage race title and then I had
seven more fights in quick succession so
I was ten and now and then there was
auditions for the UFC in London so for
the ultimate fight over the phone yeah
so I went down to that unfortunately I
sound like such a bragging bastard there
but fortunately everyone else that was
auditioning at light-heavyweight I'd
knocked out in the first round so rut
wasn't really much of an audition
process do you know really these guys
come on so yeah I believe finds a job in
the UFC 29 or 29 29 this is so the most
or now I think Jim Miller just got the
most wins I think he's got 30 now but I
still got the most no no no he got the
most fights yeah I still got the most
wins who's who's on you don't mean GSP a
tie for the most wins oh yeah
no no I wish it with 29 wins I don't
know what it was like 22 or something
like that I'm not sure honestly I don't
know I don't follow my record you know
I'm not sure was the toughest fight you
ever had Chavez fight believe it or not
not a big name Matt Hamill deaf guy and
all the fire so we were on the same
season and like for me when I was
younger fighting was everything that's
all I had you know my family had no
money I had nothing I was bullied all
the time for being poor and [ __ ] like
that because we grew up in kind of a
nicer neighborhood and I hated it so all
I had was the fact that could be anyone
else up and that's what fueled me in
life you know and I've seen a lot of
violence so when I went on the automat
fire [ __ ] this guy was my main
competition by far he was great his
wrestling was ridiculous we're not
wrestling in England if he just touched
yep cool you got flying through the air
Weston was that good so because I was
such a competitor you know we were
brought in heads all the time we didn't
get along now you know I wish
the best I'm sure he's a great guy
anyway we didn't fire on the show we got
injured I ended up winning the whole
thing I had a few fights in the UFC was
UFC 75 at the L 2 arena and they're like
typical cocky bastard I'm remember
walking out waving everybody waving at
my mom all smiles thinking I'm gonna
wipe the floor with this guy fight
starts we go out there mad enough a
minute into it he's got me in a headlock
here and just repeatedly like you watch
your little brother right blood pouring
out my [ __ ] nose everyone I'm
thinking this is not going to plan I
mean beat the [ __ ] living daylights
out of it now next couple of rounds I
did just enough to make it a competitive
find you love getting the decision a lot
of people were pissed off pissed pissed
about the decision you know it was a
super close fight you know but yeah
probably Matt Hamill which is even like
one of the superstar names you want to
hear you know and people want to hear
Anderson Silva or whatever that was a
tough who's the guy that got the squat
he got he we yeah he's got a win on John
John John John which is ridiculous that
should be that should be a no contest
but whatever you know I think we should
give Matt Hamill the [ __ ] like I'm
amazed schools from way now that's a
picture him like he's to get ya know
he's gonna zoom in on his shirt of
record and that is like in like a big
fault off father's head yeah he was
amazing he was great but he he he
couldn't hear it was enough yeah he's
very very [ __ ] dad because I we'd be
on the ultimate fire and we were on the
same team and with the training and this
was like why we wouldn't get along
because we'd be training and [ __ ] and
we'd be sparring him end of the round so
we'd stop and I'd stop in the face of
what the [ __ ] he had in terms of that
giving him [ __ ] the signs and
everything and not to mention the fact
that they say when you're deaf you've
got a heightened sense of your
surroundings and I would think that when
everybody in the room stopped fighting
he'd realized that all we've stopped but
he'd still get a couple of sucker
punches in army man
nice deficit oh my [ __ ] this you [ __ ]
dude you [ __ ] knew you cheap shiny
[ __ ] interpreter was just at
trashing you who's like yeah what a
[ __ ] I'm like you're gonna get outside
you're gonna [ __ ] get it I'm gonna
break your fingers
you're never gonna interpret anything
you like nothing funny [ __ ] yeah you
know there's people that are still
fighting that when you given talk you
could tell that they're gonna have a
long yeah a couple years it's a I don't
see that with you know no for sure well
you know sometimes when I'm doing my
podcast now I feel very sharp when I do
the podcast sometimes like that I can
listen nothing [ __ ] am i slurring my
words so don't feel like I'm I think it
isn't slurred my thinking I think way
too fast I'm five steps ahead of them a
mouse able to carry me i taunt you
faster you don't have that busted chair
Holloway Holloway yes on the interview
how did you know he was concussed I did
I didn't know if he was concussed we
were doing an interview we come up on
the big screen and he's on there and
he's like my name's like I'm prior to
like the studio making our sound you
know got through to him I was whispering
to Kenya saying [ __ ] man he doesn't look
good
you know max he's a great guy no max is
a great guy he's the best awesome guy
and so we start and I might and you know
we have cards in front of us of what
questions we've got to say that we've
arranged in the production meeting
beforehand
but I'm like I can't go off this year
I've got to ask him I said yo max you
feeling good quite remember what I said
you feeling good buddy you know is that
yeah I'm like because you look like you
are for sleeping you kind of slow in
your words you good is that uh yeah um
I'm good I'm good I'm like all right all
right and then afterwards I sent him a
message because I felt bad because I was
like I had injuries but you still want
to fight as a fire you don't give a [ __ ]
about your injuries and you still want
to go and that's that's the fire inside
you and I thought if somebody was
highlighting one of my injuries on TV
I'd be pissed at that guy so after as I
felt bad I was like yo max sorry man I
wasn't trying to an enemy message me
back with by this point the news of
broken that he had a car
[ __ ] and he wasn't able to fight and he
messing me back he said no thank you
thank you so much thank you because
because of that I'm not fighting and I
want to say thank you so he took it so
well he's a great guy when do they get
cool custard after Luna gum no I think
it was I think I don't know this from
the horse's mouth but I think a few days
probably what I heard on the grapevine
around the UFC you got knocked out in
training a few days before but I could
be wrong there that's what someone told
me but that's what that's what I was
hearing yeah you know I think there was
not this collar last well I don't want
to mention any names I looked at the
card my song name on there that you
could tell he's already gone hmm yes
it's and I was like why they let this
poor bastard fight he lost again and
it's like that comes a point where you
could tell her you don't have to be a
genius that's something the screws are
rad know for sure and were you scared it
was a very point no I wasn't I wasn't
and never was I was always fearless you
know as a fire you can't you can't no
you can't you can't that might say you
can't that mine Sam I retired because
what this I hear is [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] so Barbara but I see fires
out there and in the fire a certain way
and you know it's not smart the idea of
firing professional find skilled
fighters to hit and not get hit you know
this [ __ ] bravado or I don't care man
I'll take one to get in there and now
it's stupid as you said boxing is a
sweet science there's a science to
fighting there's a science to martial
arts you know these you know a lot of
people in the UFC I'm not saying I'm not
a knucklehead because I've certainly had
my moments out like an idiot sometimes
but there's a lot of people that are
martial arts defiers you know and they
go out there and they have the chin
carried in the air and they take a ton
of shots and it's great for the crowd
and it's great for the UFC and I enjoy
it and it's exciting as hell but I worry
for those guys that do that and fight
that way because as you say you can see
with some guys as well and I don't want
to say this with you know you know see
you see isn't a capo genius no I think
exactly and this is genetic disposition
to it as well because there's guys who
take a lot of do it you've got a you
know you're the most you know one of the
most fights in the UFC you
been in a lot of [ __ ] wars as well
you know I think that you know it
depends on the way you're made up you
know I think some certain people smoke
cigarettes their entire life they get
cancer right and it's just it is what it
is no it's it's a 50/50 yeah you know 50
you know they smoke more cigarettes in
China then yeah we do here they are less
percentage of cancer really is that
acupuncture no saki a second and all
that type of [ __ ] really you know listen
you never know you never know what your
jaw is gonna take it could be three
punches or twenty until you start
getting a glass jaw yeah well same thing
with your coconut how many now for sure
how many you know my dick has an
offensive center in football how many
times can ya come in the head you know
as a [ __ ] linebacker as a quarterback
I was watching the game the other day
you can't barely touch the quarterback
no more right yeah you can't barely
touch him no more you know the amount of
times after a fight when I've lost badly
and I have no idea what's going on but
I'm smart enough to know to act that I'm
okay
you know what I mean some I'm trying to
piece everything together very carefully
and as to what's going on and and then a
couple of days later a thing back to
that I'm not man I was so out of it you
do in interviews and you talk to people
and you don't know what's going on can't
remember stuff I mean the worst one
so when I got knocked out against Dan
Anderson UFC 100 and that was backstage
and I had no idea what happened I don't
know why at fault I thought I was
fighting in three months I thought I was
saying to my manager why did I fight is
that what do you mean I'm like I wasn't
fighting tonight
you know is that dude we got to get to
the hospital I'm another arm good I get
in the shower second later I'd walk out
and they'd get a good quick cuz everyone
was round now the UFC people doctors and
[ __ ] my what's going on is that [ __ ]
now you need to go to a hospital no no
no no I'm good I'm good two minutes
later come here what's going on you know
and this went on for a while and they
were trying to get me to the hospital I
was denies it no no I'm good I'm good
anyway long story short talk to the
hospital I shared an ambulance with
Frank Mir after he'd you saw his ass
kicked off Brock Lesnar and we're both
in the back of the ambulance
like sorry [ __ ] and I'm like
hey what's up Frank and then I was like
[ __ ] like what's up um never
mind it's all coming back to and now I
realize now I know you know it's a tough
game it's a tough game you know you got
to know when to get out the end of the
story is that Frank Mir was never in
that band what the [ __ ] were you
thinking about to go get into the
Octagon
oh man look crazy this guy oh yeah I was
I did for Alice mania which is a Jason
Alice is a radio personality Sirius XM
who I've known a little while now and
yeah I did the first ever mmm a comedian
fight they never did MMA always like
like boxing between my fans and [ __ ] and
they have like rollerskating fights and
[ __ ] stupid it's just it's just dumb
yeah yeah so so so I'm cornering him
okay DT sold me that it was gonna be a
real MMA all right cool yeah whatever
I respect you lose you know and he was
pushing himself when he was training and
he's doing all I heard and that was like
oh [ __ ] this guy's taking this seriously
come down to my house and you know
whatever we did a couple of training
sessions drove him to Vegas he's getting
on light you know my weight my way
[ __ ] L did the scales and bummer but
I'm like he's getting on like I was for
[ __ ] like the biggest buyer my high
you think he was buying where are we
going here right we get there we're
checking into the hotel and I know how
this feels because when you check into a
hotel new rooms not ready it's annoying
as [ __ ] I check in my rooms ready it
loses rooms not ready and is that what
that because he was due to be on the
scale to weigh in in about 30 minutes
and he had to cut a little bit away and
he's freaking out and this and that I'm
at loose it's okay so kids pool tomorrow
and could it they said no this is
[ __ ] this shouldn't be happening
he has a breakdown he's on his hands and
knees in the lobby of the hard one
suitcase open throwing [ __ ] everywhere
I'm looking to this day Donald what he
was looking for is shorts or something
to Auschwitz where sweet sweat into
Panama what are you doing get off the
[ __ ] Anna I said Louis Louis listen
listen you gotta enjoy
this process man that's what my coach
said to me when I took the world towel
round two weeks noise
I always stressed how stressing myself
by the way I knew you will [ __ ] win
no thank you very thing in the air he
was too cocky Luke but I and you fight
for your life well thank you very much
but a JC I always stress on training
counts because I want to win you know
and I feel the pressure and Perillo
pulled me to one side he said Mike
listen tell me a two-week training camp
can you calm down enjoy this process
you said you knows maybe you never fight
for a world title ever again you know so
let's enjoy it now let's enjoy this
moment and I thought you know what is
absolutely right was fantastic advice
and I didn't was like a weight lifted
off my shoulders so I got to loosen my
Lewis you might never fight in the UFC
yes sir I'm never under MMA fight again
but this is a big moment for you you
hear there's a Wayne out there you know
lose the chip on your shoulder enjoy
this process and he looked at me like he
wanted to kill me basically said go [ __ ]
yourself you should have brought the
scale my weight 205 pounds I waited at 2
or 2.6 but I didn't know yeah and we
were late and when I'm running late when
I'm in route dude I'm really rude to cab
drivers because if I'm running late for
something he was a [ __ ] I wanted to beat
the piss out of it I was like oh my god
I've by my talk so hard am i I want to
[ __ ] him up
this [ __ ] I'm driving into bags
I'm putting him up I'm taking it for
physical therapy I'm doing this I'm
driving he may be I'm picking him up in
LA I finish UFC tonight [ __ ] get
me wait for an hour and a half and there
and then he gets that after me seeing
him a car for an hour others take me to
a Starbucks I'm like wow take him down
to my house my wife's cooking taking him
everywhere driving to Vegas
kicking off throwing [ __ ] everywhere in
the Hard Rock I'm like the [ __ ] is going
on with this guy cuz I don't get spoke
wouldn't you like that I don't accept it
because I tell people to [ __ ] off but I
like Luis and I have respect I'm a
future electric ghost and so my or eyes
alone buy him a [ __ ] [ __ ] and
anyway long story short I was warming up
for the fight I turn up he's my wife's
anniversary 19 years but still you know
I got corner Luis is that 20 shut up and
and the band and I'm in there and Kyle
Kingsbury is the main event okay he's
dancing in silver like speedo silver
speedos high on magic mushrooms dancing
to the dirty Dan dancing the dirty
dancing soundtrack high as a [ __ ]
kite am i what's going on I look how
there's guys on roller skates punching
each other in the face while the whole
crowd throws dodge balls okay I'm up
what the [ __ ] is going on and I'm
wrapping his hands he's [ __ ] [ __ ]
there's like midgets in the [ __ ] ring
and there's all this annoying dodge
balls and he's the main of its higher
magic mushrooms dancing and I believe
the fight happens where was fighting
boxing Jason else but he had a thick
mushroom and I'm thinking to myself few
months ago I was main event Madison
Square Garden against George st. Pierre
[ __ ] me how the mighty have fallen
this one is come to my life right now
but he was great he went out there
performed it was it was a great
performance
how did he get into a beef with this all
right it wasn't it a beef Ryan O'Neal
Danish immigrants I'm friends of Ryan
he's great dude great comic it was
personal for a while it did though Ari
Shaffir and just same trip we were
supposed to fight each other at this
event and Sam sort of sparked this
little beef between me and Ryan he was
like these guys should fight because
Ryan apparently was a Taekwondo black
belt and he had always talked about
wanting to get into a fight and me I'm
just a [ __ ] I do an MMA podcast I've
never trained today in my life I was I
was a goth kid in high school
there's no athleticism in my life a golf
kid god oh god I was like pretend that
y'all had a poor upbringing when you
were the gold eyeliner long hair melon
master teachers drummer in a band I
wasn't like a [ __ ] tough guy kid I
was a toughest out of the goth kids so
I'll protect my fat got friends you know
I'm saying but I've always had like I've
always wanted to fight and I've always
wanted to like test myself and see what
would happen I've always like been
willing to so he's talked [ __ ] just been
willing to fight like it you know
the dude I don't know like there's just
people that are willing to if somebody
you know starts going [ __ ] crazy on
the train car certain people step up and
[ __ ] and say hey dude shut the [ __ ] up
I'm one of those guys right so no mouth
no action is what you say [ __ ] no no
no I'm totally if somebody and I are so
but so he sort of set it off on Twitter
and I made a joke I was like I fear no
clown meaning like I'll fight any
[ __ ] comic comics or [ __ ] like you
know whatever except for joe version so
then he talked about on his podcast and
then it's became this thing but you sort
of talk I didn't know this guy at all
I'd never met him at that point
and we just sort of talking [ __ ] back
and forth here and there and then
eventually just turned into dude all
fights you have this [ __ ] event if
you want to do it we'll train for three
months we'll do it and yeah and it was
the reality is like I think it was a
really cool thing to just test myself as
a Jew away for three months I trained
for three months really lost a [ __ ] turn
away putting stuff to a puppet regime
out there I was very impressed you know
how serious he was taking it that's why
I was so light [ __ ] my mind exploded
when I saw the event because I thought
we were going to let a legit like one of
those like low-level fights at the Hard
Rock at the joint you know what I mean
legit MMA although a [ __ ] cool man
why don't Louis yeah respect get that my
next Lord's it what look it was it's a
[ __ ] show but what you know it's a lot
of fun it was a lot of fun it's a lot of
stupid it's not nobody's taking super
seriously I didn't but I didn't think it
was stupid I think that you learned
something
adding that you I would love to be able
to [ __ ] go jiu-jitsu tournament I'm
petrified yeah
petrified petrified to go and just do a
masters blue belt thing yeah yeah for
sure I mean I understand I mean as I
said early well I know I uh I will
[ __ ] improve so much 100% you need to
set those do you need to set those goals
and that's the other thing is like I
lost a [ __ ] ton are we doing I'm doing a
special in December I'm filming in New
York do you know how much training for
that fight help me with this special
absolutely preparing and thinking
because I think now I'm like dude I
prepared for a fight I got myself
physically ready to go three
three-minute rounds you know I learned
jujitsu I was tap
blue belts up were [ __ ] training for
a year and a half two years I was doing
just like what did you do - are you
cycling dude I have dude I blocked my
shoulder six weeks for the fight broke
my hand ten days but that's why I kept
on having to rewrap my hand it was a
great moment because it goes dude I was
a ghetto rewrap it again is ignite
I'm not [ __ ] wrapping your hand again
your hand [ __ ] hurts it's not gonna
hurt as soon as you walk out there you
know the Adrenaline's room you're not
gonna feel it buddy I can't right behind
the perfect way you're saying it sir if
your hands hurt your hands hurt wrapping
it isn't gonna make it any better when
you're out there you're not gonna feel a
goddamn thing no more [ __ ] bandages
you know we're all 75 we're using nine
thousand rolls of tape we're done I got
out there I'm as soon as I stepped up
there I didn't think about my hand my
shoulder it was [ __ ] crazy these he
great he did yeah it was it was off yeah
I won uh it's on you - yeah yeah it was
good it was a really cool experience to
like dude I don't know man
I sort of like psyching myself up in my
head about like what it meant to set a
goal and like accomplish it and have
teaching that to my son and like what
that means and never circle my dude this
guy's trying to [ __ ] take that away
from my son
that lesson indeed I don't know when you
have that it was a crazy type of
motivation that I had and I think you
need look to get in shape it was [ __ ]
great but also just to sort of like hit
a goal and like be so specific about
that's what I miss about fired
ya know people say you said to me before
do you miss it it's like you know listen
of course you know it's exciting and all
the rest of it and the money's good and
blah and you know I like to compete
that's what I do but no not really I you
know I want to be successful I've got a
lot of things going on outside the
electron so I'm happy in that regard but
I do miss the fight that when you when
you got a fire and you're gonna train
for a fire and you got to do a fight
camp and you got to win the fight and
you get your team together at the start
of the campaign you sit down and your
wife makes dinner for everybody and you
play the fights and we all sit down
strategize I'm coming with a game plan
and I'm 37 pounds overweight and say
okay the nutritionist sets the [ __ ]
diet and all this type of stuff when
we've set a plan and you get the white
board out and we figure out the [ __ ]
training regime and all these very
scientific and you're on a mission and
you got a team and you're on a mission
you know and it's exciting that's what I
mean
real goal that's when I'm okay we're all
working towards one goal flying out to
[ __ ] China or wherever to take on
Kong Lee on August 14th okay
and they were all gonna fight together
you know and I missed that side of it
and I miss the the quest I miss the
quest in the mission side of it you know
it's a beautiful thing in that regard
when you're tired you were said I'm
staying in announcer oh yeah yeah the
things that you wait to do yeah I mean I
mean obviously I did the podcast with
Lois with which you know he's blowing up
massively thoroughly I enjoy it do a lot
of stuff with Fox soon it's gonna be
ESPN so I'll be switching over to ESPN
which is a shame great time at Fox UFC
just recently offered me commentating
contract as well so there's that I do a
lot of acting do wholesome TV shows just
hosted a massive show was gonna break
soon on Netflix I'm involved with a
sports gambling company a fancy sports
company called play land that's blowing
up like crazy
got UFC gyms I just bought the rights to
UFC gym in England were open in 110 gyms
in England over the next 10 years I've
got a lot of things going on high school
jail yeah no no no no no that's another
reason why I felt safe to step away now
you know cuz I should health-wise have
retired a long time ago but I wasn't
ready I wasn't financially there I
hadn't networked enough CC I knew I was
always on borrowed time ever since my I
got [ __ ] up you know so I was just
trying to stack ships making make
contacts Network set myself up and
that's all I was trying to do the whole
time you know so yeah and then when I
came to a point where I was ready I was
comfortable to step away but I was
actually flying up to the the gasps
digital studios in New York to record a
copy of the problem session of the
podcast and I was on the plane and I was
watching this movie called the
journeyman this English actor and
director Paddy Considine and he plays a
boxer that was a world champion and he
wins the fight and goes on to his wife
and he's sitting there and he's having a
cup of tea after the fans chatting to
his wife anyway he ends up getting brain
damage and he's [ __ ] in a big way you
know and I've had a lot of injuries but
my eyes the main thing and I don't want
to go blind and I was thinking this just
ain't worth it man you know how many for
how much money is going to be enough
how many fights do you need how much did
you even eat you know my friend said to
me said my if you lost your vision cuz
that problem with my good eye as well is
that you know like even now every time I
turn like that I get flashes in my eye
at flowers all the time it's [ __ ]
he said if you went blind there's no
amount of money that you wouldn't give
to get your vision back so he's just not
worth it and then when I was watching
that movie I was like yeah yeah yeah
it [ __ ] hit home and I got on the
podcast radio acid yeah I'm retired yeah
he told literally minutes before we got
on the podcast he was like I'm gonna
announce my retirement hey you were
talking about possibly doing it yeah I'm
thinking about the idea but I was good
in a while you were there before the
title shot no no for sure I was yeah
yeah but but I was flirting with
seriously do now is I love one more I
love one more you know yeah there was
some closure maybe we got the title man
yeah no I know that's used yeah no I it
was for me it was a big thing because
and how much did that helped me with
setting up everything else well I mean
the reality is like I know because we
did the podcast together you know it was
huge but for me it was more of a
personal thing when I won the title
because you know we you know I I don't
like to go on and [ __ ] feel sorry for
myself but when I was younger you know
it's it's it's all a heart you know and
that's what I pride in my cell phone
which is a stupid thing to pride
yourself on being able to be anyone in a
fight you know but it was all a [ __ ]
hard and then I got to the UFC and I you
know I was a loudmouth I saw I talked a
lot of [ __ ] you know and you know I was
just in the mall you know of course of
loss around news but everyone said he
he'll never win this Bell
he just guys don't good enough yeah he's
tough what he will never do it and
that's all everyone ever said everyone
ever said and you have no idea how much
that ever motivated me you know and then
when I got it I was like I don't give a
[ __ ] about the money art for me with the
personal satisfaction of looking through
all of the fires in the division all the
critics all the reporters all the
journalists my teachers at [ __ ]
school everyone said [ __ ] you
look at me now
a big [ __ ] you is a big motivator in
life now of course it is it's a big [ __ ]
I think I think about mr. Lefever
my principal every almost every day any
time I cash a check any time I do
anything that I'm like I feel
accomplished there
him telling me when I was like in the
eleventh grade you'll never graduate
from this high school he said those
words and I graduated from this high
school and then I went on to [ __ ] do
no I'm not gonna [ __ ] on teachers or
principals but I think something pretty
[ __ ] extraordinary compared to a
principal of some [ __ ] shitty high
school you know and by the way for some
some adult to ever get to a point where
your first of your teaching kids you the
principal you're the dude that's
supposed to inspire the teachers of your
children to get to a point where you're
gonna tell a kid in your school that
will never graduate from your school
that's why they tell you the truth
listen you know some people do need to
have their parameters set you know the
guys walking into walls over there okay
he's never gonna [ __ ] be the next CEO
of Apple okay happy with the job at
McDonald's you know it's so weird how I
always my goal with comedy was not to be
louis c.k Richard Pryor was just not to
make it be a waste of my time hmm
I never thought about being a
millionaire I never thought about that
stuff I just never wanted that at the
time I put in this like when you're
doing comedy hate years and you quit
that's gonna haunt you for the rest of
your [ __ ] life
mmm you got to play the hand out to the
end dude you people that quit in comedy
it's bizarre I meet them all that stops
yeah my heart's now how would you feel
if me and Michael Bisping we're training
at that same karate school and you know
I honestly I love it I used to like
Bisbing up and training besides now I'm
an engineer and Michael Bisping is the
world champion of the UFC yeah you seem
like a super market you quit because you
like the girl but you know you could you
talk you out of it and what you do what
do you feel like today that you were
really light Michael because I think
anybody who does stand-up comedy I don't
know about fighting but it's probably
the truth for fighting as well to the
point where you're putting yourself you
don't risk you know career-wise where
you're taking the real chance and I've
had I've run into a few people where
they quit you see it on the face
and you know they gave up their dream
because you don't put a few years into
something like Santo comedy which
[ __ ] sucks in the beginning if it's
not your dream if you don't want to be
Richard Pryor up there whoever the [ __ ]
it is that you inspired you you're
looking at somebody who actually gave up
on the dream and you know it and they
know you know it and that sucks
nothing bothers me more when I hang out
with you for three or four years and we
talk comedy and one night we actually go
get a sandwich and we talk about comedy
and then three years later I walk into
the audition
and you're the guy working the camera oh
yeah you become a producer or you've
become a director you want to light my
fire mmm that lights my fire I can't be
judgmental I just say you know for me
what when I got into fire my my my god I
remember sitting with my dad and
game-planning yet because MMA was
nothing in the UK it was nothing there
was no [ __ ] scene whatsoever and
everything everybody said if you get
into MMA for money you're making a big
mistake and that was the only reason why
I was doing it they only [ __ ] reason
and the goal was to make enough money to
be able to go to college and study
something and then be able to get a real
job down the [ __ ] line you know I
remain as opposed to the shitty no boy
was a bad dream to me to me it was a
dream of that you know I'll be able to
get a decent job for once I do UFC even
back then there wasn't a lot of money
being thrown around in 2003 do you know
what I mean do you know it wasn't like
now you know especially for a kid from
England that there's no shows in England
or nothing you know what I mean could
make enough money if I can maybe get you
know 50 grand put away and then go to
college from the family for a few years
run for clothes would you I have no
[ __ ] idea no no I had no idea no but
that was a stupid [ __ ] day is what
I'm gonna do okay I'm gonna be a cage
fighter and enough money and go to
college but I would be Jam did you ever
say to yourself man maybe I'll go to
college and be yeah a lawyer yeah well I
signed up but I was a I was an idiot
could never follow what you say
to be a structural engineer engine are
you but I didn't I didn't make it to the
first [ __ ] class no IIIi didn't make
it the enrollment process was too much
for me you know because I didn't a bus
and got to Blackburn was another town
and calls and be organized College what
was your first dream my first dream yeah
my college and then the lawyer maybe I
never was I was I really got into music
when I was a kid I was a drummer in a
band salty black flour and yeah we it
was always like did I [ __ ] grew up
when did you grow up well I was so aware
of money when I was like four I'm my kid
now I said the other day I was like yeah
I grew up poor James he's five he goes
what's poor and I was just an adorable
sentence really what's poor like he does
he has no idea his don't understanding
what money is or what you know but time
I was five I knew my mom was on welfare
I knew we were on food stamps I knew I
was aware that we didn't make money that
we were like you know it was a [ __ ] up
thing so I was like I was like I don't
know like the first real dream I want to
be a pro-wrestler when I was a kid I
wanted to be junk Livan down you are all
bad you made a dude no I know but I
wanted to be a martial arts movie actor
that's what I wanted to be so bad no I
don't want to I mean yes I'm not far a
[ __ ] doing pretty happy now we're
gonna great martial arts movie at the
end of the year coming out called triple
threat it's gonna be sick check it out
but dog died halfway through making
water so you see half with Tony yeah eat
always use a really good martial artist
Tiger Chan Michel Jarre white Scott
Adkins is it's it's got what they claim
is the best martial arts cast available
coolest [ __ ] I just right guy bumped
into him eating then and I didn't say
nothing I know he's friends with Eddie
mm-hmm I didn't say a [ __ ] word he
was with his wife and he got up and he
goes he joined karate what's happened
talking to him like I know pretending
doesn't like dogs though he doesn't like
dogs cuz when my dog died you
and you wanna talk about anyway salsa
so I was sitting there it's hearts [ __ ]
we're in the window you see how much his
dog affects them we mentioned then you
mentioned Michael Jawa and those stories
actually talents as I said he's the man
he's a great guy he's a gentleman he's
an awesome human being he really is but
as I say not a lover of dogs because but
dogs died and I'm trying to not cry and
we're sitting there in between takes and
I want to talk about it because on my
mind I'm like your mic is that yeah
what's up no my [ __ ] dog - man I just
had to put my dog down any guys oh yeah
say yeah no and then looked away and
that was it and I was like [ __ ] and
anyway Michael Vick's cuz so anyway so a
few hours later we're back in the same
position it's just me and him there
again and I'm like all I'm thinking was
my dog I just put him down a few hours
ago and I'm like I want to talk about it
but he wasn't interested before but
maybe didn't quite understand me because
of my accent
you know I your mic is that it was up oh
my [ __ ] man
let's put my dog down before and he goes
yeah you told me you liked it yesterday
sadly I got a text from Donald Cerrone
okay another text an email I think goes
dead looking for you to do this movie
but you gotta do it on Monday oh yeah I
had you guys I was like I'm not going
you should have done the big no I've
come anytime know some things that you
do it was a six outlets it's a six hour
flight from West Point five hour flight
from West Palm to LA I would have had to
go home change clothes hug my kid and
get on another plane to Utah then they
connecting flight the higher the ball
falls and then it's an hour drive the
location listen guys know I love doing
movies but I don't like going crazy oh I
love is no more I have such a freedom
with the podcast and I
done so many good projects and so many
shitty projects that now really picky
and I know exactly well that's great
that's a dream by the way it's yeah Sam
good morning and doing what the [ __ ] you
want to do listen whatever his name said
it best you know what the [ __ ] is that
saying Walt Disney know about that
[ __ ] it's it's when you could go from
a Harriet area with full enthusiast
Winston Churchill said successes when
you go from area to area with enthusiasm
you know that's why you can't let it be
a [ __ ] DJ full-time to you was 65 hey
there's also got British rhythm so well
no but the whole thing is there's some
be surprised you'd be surprised I want
to say it awareness anymore that want to
do a few different things you know and
it wasn't exactly what you went for you
take out do you think I wasn't again to
what did you think I thought I get so
long as you're when I moved here I
thought I would be a texture at best
ever like if I we came election a movie
I'd be great than I booked the national
commercial my got a [ __ ] disaster
so you never really [ __ ] know until
and I loved acting for years until it
just got to the point where I'd rather
say my own lines especially when the
shitty [ __ ] lines yeah no I know I
[ __ ] night I do a lot of auditions
right now and you know I've prepared for
them I work with merit and coaching you
know I do good auditions these days
faster even still some ridiculous
strength is auditioning yeah I [ __ ]
killin auditions kill psychologically I
know the psychological part of it you
got to get the the people to like you
you gotta like you I go early and I sit
by the door and I listen to what the
three [ __ ] idiots are saying and I
know how to stretch a line out into two
lines that's because I went on five
years I went on all the major auditions
and until one day that I took the stage
and I combined until your audition so it
started clicking for me once I took what
I did on stage and put it into an
audition I would go on for these
one-liners and I go ha
chemical one-liner hey it's great to
meet you I couldn't book that until I
figured out how to turn those one lines
into two lines
oh and stay in that room a lot longer
than everybody else
the key is to stay in that room when
you've got an audition you see people ya
know for sure you see people walking in
and out you're heartbroken
yeah you don't want to be one of those
people I want to be one of those people
no I'm like oh my god please I don't
have to do another take cool
I love booking the job it's not good
it's not a good sign you want to do
another how do you feel about it I'm
sure you want to do another that's a
good sign like they want you to do
better yeah I do everything but touch
the cast director I kick chairs I fly
over they are the 90s I used to do it
one time I ripped my pants and my
ballsack fell out I had no underwear and
they asked I asked what they saw the
Cuban I grow and they hired me
it's what is it what's that show on CBS
four years how I dated your mother if
you ever seen me on there man extra oh
well as they hired me because my balls
came on they laughed when I got that was
the wrong type of directors like we
don't want this [ __ ] guy these balls
are too small listen was a pleasure
having one thanks Joey
what's the podcast believe you me yeah
okay and you do it twice a week there we
do yeah we do definitely once a week
sometimes twice a week once a leave you
may check it out all the usual [ __ ]
spots yeah
yeah we do it we do it you can get it
for free everywhere you get podcast for
free you can download it and watch it on
YouTube the latest few episodes or was
on YouTube and yeah it's fine it's great
to it I love you ain't tomorrow at the
Comedy Store
yeah tomorrow night Comedy Store I got a
little Greg Garcia thing first for the
for the guest book of Allah shoot over
that great I love it the Legion of
skanks this week at the Comedy Store
also I'm running my hour I'm filming my
special little shake almost presents
Lucia Gomez December 9th in New York
City insisting he's that well it's a
presents' michael best boys yeah we know
you named [ __ ] that's the joke
that's it you know I'm doing it I'm
doing it in at the cutting room which is
a really cool rock club in New York and
I'm gonna be touring if you go to Lucy a
ghost because
I'm touring all over the country right
now I'm running in La Jolla comedy so on
Thursday night I'll be in Philly of the
Atlantic City I'm gonna say what the
[ __ ] you congratulations on you buddy
[ __ ] the a gentleman outside the
Octagon on inside the Octagon
I stole my--my busting my balls after
you beat up man where is ma'am no time I
have no idea he's got a beat I'm saying
the sound was I don't know man
he took the beat why wouldn't I say to
you after that you came to the table and
you in the restaurant were you with
Robert yes no no and then you even did a
joy karate video yeah
you were [ __ ] that we were sitting
then you came over to the table you were
gentlemen I'm like wow you know usually
[ __ ] some guys are just weird but you
always very nice then we took that plane
that morning oh yeah yeah yeah you
[ __ ] smell tremendous when he got
bent like this [ __ ] he's been
going since 2:00 in the afternoon
thank you guys I want to thank Michael
Bisping and Louis J Gomez for stopping
by the church what's happening now
also don't forget October 25th to the
27th I'm at hilarities in Cleveland my
man Jorge Perez and then November 8th
the tunnel rat tour starts after the
Netflix special gets dropped on October
30th
myself and Kate quickly it got them for
the New York Comedy Festival Thursday
Friday and Saturday five puppet shows
and they will sell out no [ __ ] around
so don't [ __ ] around I'm just letting
you know but before we get into anything
listen I wanna talk to you watching
football is fun let me tell you
something it's a lot better when you got
a little action on the games and you're
willing a little money guys you've heard
me talk about this for weeks and some of
yous are still not making money and I
doing dick whether you're an expert or
rookie you should be betting at my
bookie you like Joey why listen if
you're the kind of guy likes to bet a
little
a lot like playing numbers on the
roulette you can create a huge part way
at my bookie is that works you pick
three teams to win and if you hit all
three of them you could turn a yardstick
into 600 hours that's 100 to 6 there's
so much to bet on
you got playoff baseball you got World
Series baseball you got football
you got the fights you got hockey listen
my book is the one bet I know you'll be
happy with now I recommend these guys
because I trust them they've been around
for years and they got great online
reviews and their mobile site is easy to
use so listen you don't want to make no
money
keep sitting there like a [ __ ] move
my bookie will match your first deposit
dollar for dollar so if you put in a 200
you get 200 from them but you gotta join
today right now don't [ __ ] around no
more dog you've been [ __ ] around for
four or five weeks it's game it's the
six weeks in the NFL whatever the [ __ ]
it is and you still you're not making
any my buck come on here you go log on
to my bookie right now tonight and W
Jesus use promo code shirt see you Hur
CH and you'll get your first deposit
match a hundred percent that's a hundred
percent you understand me
use promo code Church my bookie you play
you win you get paid now some of you
[ __ ] gamble so you've been
losing and you're losing your hand let
me tell you something right losing sixty
six percent of men lose their hair by
the age of 35 nothing to be ashamed of
the thing is when you start to know this
hair loss it's too late it's easier to
keep the hair that you have and to
replace his hair your loss understand me
is that hairline slow he's starting to
move back when your uncle Joey look at
my hairline starting to move backwards
but what do I care 55 I did what I had
to do anyway and he balks watch yet
how you feeling ear from now if it's
business as usual up there I asked do
you want a bald spot to pop up or do you
want to do something about it first do
you want your hairline to recede or do
you want to do something about it first
why do guys turn a weird solution or do
nothing when they can turn to medicine
in science listen I got the answer you
ready write this down for hems calm it's
a one-stop shop for hell
skincare and sexual wellness if you know
what I'm talking about for men what
you're gonna do is this alright
what we do is hims connects you with
real doctors not these guys from
Yugoslavia real doctors and medical
grade solutions to treat hair loss what
they do is they they use well-known
generic equivalents to name brands
supplement prescriptions to help you
keep your hair
this ain't no snake oil or no pills you
get at 7-eleven or some gas station
these are prescription solutions backed
by science guys it's tough going bald
it's a reality we all have to face but
listen for hims makes it easy for you
for hims calm you got no waiting room
the awkward person or doctor visits and
you save hours by going to for him it's
easy you answer a few questions
a doctor will review it and they can
prescribe your product and guess what
they shipped directly to your door
nobody needs to know nothing now the
church family you gotta try out month
two hymns for five hours that's five
hours that's five hours today not
tomorrow today right now while supplies
last go to the website for full details
this will cost you hundreds if you went
to the doctor or you went to some
pharmacy I'm gonna save you a ton of
money for five hours for one month go to
four hymns calm slash Joey again
that's four hymns calm slash Joey now
let's talk about eating because you know
this is the time of year when you gotta
eat a little bit and you gotta eat
healthy I got the answer for you blue
apron you know why cuz it deliver
farm-fresh ingredients and a step by
step recipe right to your door and
everything is measured out to the T
here's how it works all right you choose
chef design recipes we deliver fresh
seasonally inspired ingredients and you
can cook an incredible meal in as little
as twenty minutes I just told you 20
minutes you got home from work you're
tired you don't want to walk around you
don't want at all get delivery and have
some guy putting his fingers in your
pizza no no no no dinner and as little
as 20 minutes every week at at least
three recipes a built with your busy
schedule mind where blueprint has done
the meal prep for you they prepared the
sauce
spices and the ingredients all right
quick and easy recipe options with
insanely delicious flavors get rid of
the grocery list and let the way prett
do the meal prep for you now we offer a
wide variety of recipes bursting with
flavor look what we got this week I'm
gonna tell you what we got right now and
I'm salivating at the mouth you
understand me
whew stir fried sweet chicken chick
chili chicken with broccoli and rice
what are you crazy ready for this one
tomato and basil pesto pizza see it
steaks with homemade steak sauce and
seared beef beef dumplings with jasmine
rice you know how to cook that stuff no
you don't but blue aprons gonna help you
right whether you're looking at it for
quick easy meals or the full Hulan airy
experience blue apron will help you
choose the recipes and the right options
so do me a favor check out this week's
menu and get your first three meals for
free at blue apron comm slash show again
that's blue apron comm slash Joey to get
your three meals for free gratis on the
blue apron a better way to cook I want
to thank blue apron I want to thank my
people over there my bookie and I want
to thank him mom for EMS comm for hims
calm for being savages and I want to
thank Michael Bisping and Louis J Gomez
I want to thank you guys for always
having my back and for always being
there for coming for the shows we've
built a nice little family I want to
thank the [ __ ]
and I'll see you guys Thursday morning
tip-top [ __ ] Magoo don't forget
next Tuesday you got the guestbook
uncle Joey's doing something that's
disgusting he gonna love it alright Lee
check that [ __ ] meal thank you